uh so do you have uh principles or
things that people can keep in mind to
try to
improve their ability to communicate
digitally right now
yeah yeah i do this relates a little bit
to you so you said you know i got in the
presidential race because
i'm looking around me and there's a lot
of huge problems and i feel like i
should try to fix some of these problems
it's an exaggeration to say i got into
communications training for the same
reason but it's
kind of like that in other words there
is a lot of really terrible coaching out
there that people get
and what i mean by that is not like that
they go take a class somewhere
there's a lot of received ideas about
how you should be better as a
communicator
and it tends to fall into two things one
is something called thought suppression
and number two is tremendously reductive
coaching
so thoughts oppression sounds like this
don't be nervous
andrew just be yourself okay so that's
thought suppression coaching you're
welcome for that by the way that's
great i know number two is like
when you speak make sure you speak in
the lower third of your voice and make
broad commanding gestures to emphasize
key points
where were these instructions when i
needed them michael
[Laughter]
don't be nervous and speak low and just
you're big
damn it i could have been president if
you had just clued me in
you know what's frightening it that kind
of feedback happens at the highest
levels too
it absolutely does and it's part of why
you see people
making the same gesture over and over
again or speaking this very reductive
manner all the time to try to emphasize
key points
no matter what they're talking about so
people get this really reductive
coaching and the thought suppression is
even worse actually because the thought
suppression like just as i told you
don't be nervous as soon as i say that
your brain goes right to thought
suppression which is like don't do this
thing your brain's obligated to look at
the thing
because it's looking at that thing now
it's thinking about that thing and how
bad you
are at not doing that thing and of
course people get kind of paralyzed in
that
so my goal is always to try to get them
out of thought suppression
and reductive coaching and try to unlock
what they do really really well
when they are back to that point other
focused as opposed to totally
self-focused
people think about like their
presentation or their presence
as being something that's all about them
and so they think like when i'm
comfortable i come across well and when
i'm uncomfortable i don't
and the funny thing is that for almost
everyone
you come across the best when you're
actually trying to communicate something
to someone else i mean
legitimately other focused so as an
example like let's say a friend comes to
you and the friend is in a crisis and
you start talking to the friend
and you hear what's happening to them i
promise you like right away
your eye contact improves right away you
begin to speak
in very technical language if that's
needed or very very colloquial and
casual language
if that's needed right away you slow
down your rate of speech
if the person's having a hard time
digesting what you're sharing you do all
that automatically and you never think
about like my
presentation skills you just do it
because you're using all of yourself to
try to reach the other person
now what happens in this format is that
i mean for
a bunch of reasons one of which is you
have a little floating box of your video
right there that you're staring at part
of the time of like what are my hands
doing what is my face doing
it's very hard not to feel
self-conscious the entire time
and be thinking about my communication
skills but what you want to do is
unlock what people do when they're
actually very focused on the other
person
and the strange thing is right now even
as weird as that camera feels
this is the vehicle that people have to
reach
everybody friends family an employer
anyone this is the vehicle we have
so helping people unlock that idea of
other focus
even when they can't help but be a
little bit self-focused is really
important
oh so it's caring about what the other
person is getting
as opposed to what you are doing at any
moment
in time so we have a couple of things
that are out there in the world that are
not
great pieces of advice for folks so so
what's the the good stuff so like if
you're asking about principles a couple
things immediately
one you alluded to this which is that
people totally underestimate how
deeply physical spoken communications
are so people think like if i've done my
homework if i've prepared my powerpoint
slides if i prep for the interview if
i've gone over the questions i might get
asked
i'm going to do great and it's not true
i mean think about how many like
scientists or subject matter experts
there are
who are phenomenal in terms of what they
know but they can't actually communicate
it
very well at all so the point is that
when you put
words into language this remarkable
coordination happens where
your diaphragm drops down your lungs
fill with air
that air then flows over your vocal
cords they vibrate they actually move in
space they make some sound
the sound amplifies throughout your
whole body and then your mouth
and your tongue and your lips and your
throat your jaw they all work together
to shape that raw sound
into words that can be understood so
it's much much closer to a sport than it
is
any kind of mental exercise that's part
of the reason why we would always warm
up we put so much focus on the campaign
of like getting yourself
physically and vocally primed to
communicate so the biggest principle
that people mess up all the time is they
think it's all about what's up here
and so much of it has to do with what's
happening down here
and you can actually prepare that and
the reason that's so liberating is
because
that you can actually control you can't
control what question you're going to
get from the interviewer you can't
but you can control how you've prepared
yourself physically and vocally
to take that question and hopefully hit
out of the park
so what would those preparation
activities look like for someone pre-job
interview
yeah so that's another big thing to
apply to which is this
people are good at something whoever's
listening is right now you're good at
something you're an expert in something
and oftentimes there's some sort of a
ritual or regimen you go through with
that thing that helps you do that thing
well so for instance if you're an
athlete warm up physically like an
athlete before you begin speaking
if you're a dancer same thing if a
singer same thing
but even if you like to do something
much more
cerebral like board games there are
still principles that can be applied
to speaking that apply one to one from
that sort of discipline
so one thing i often tell people is like
choose something you're already very
expert in
figure out what the principles are of
that and apply it to communication
that's kind of vague but i can get much
more specific if you want yeah please
yeah sure i'm just i'm imagining i'm a
person i'm a
viewer and let's say i'm listening to
this and i have a job interview tomorrow
and so then i'm like okay now thanks to
michael like i'm going to approach this
like a little bit more of a physical
activity
and then instead of cramming notes into
my head right before
the interview i'm going to do this
instead
well what you would do this instead is
you get
physically and vocally warmed up you can
do tongue twisters you can do stretches
you can get your body your breath ready
to go
there's a bunch of stuff we can share
with your your viewers and listeners if
you want to in terms of
resources and access and stuff like that
we can get to but
that's the principle of the idea then as
opposed to thinking about everything on
the page
grab a cell phone and talk into it and
give yourself rhetorical questions
if i were to get asked this question
what would i say
and start recording it if you want to if
you want to listen back if you don't
want to even the practice of just saying
this stuff out loud
helps actually get your body physically
ready to go and begins to take those
talking points
from a bunch of stuff in your head and
actually puts it into the real world
by speaking it out loud so one warm up
two
yeah yeah go ahead no no no you you you
go ahead
you just yeah warming up actually yeah
warm up actually ah but i'm pumped
warm up practice actually saying this
stuff out loud and
do it so that you're priming yourself
with a question meaning
if i were to put this in the form of a
story it might be or
if i get this question what i might say
is so you're actually practicing saying
things out loud
so you know those tv characters where
before the big interview
they always are practicing talking into
a mirror to like pump themselves up
before they go to the interview so
you're saying that actually
is wise like it's not just like
on on tv that you see characters doing
that that's actually a good idea
yeah well with a caveat sometimes being
in the mirror
makes people a bit more self-conscious
so you may want to have that visual
feedback you may not
but putting sound into words is
absolutely essential
i mean a different way to look at the
same thing is like is your 10
30 a.m phone call better than your 9 am
phone call
and for a lot of people the answer is
yeah yeah
what they've done is they used the
interview that was at 9 00 and 9 15 and
9
30 and 10 am as warm-ups to get to the
10 30.
so my point is start early put the
warm-up by yourself
early in the day before that and then
actually your body will be physically
and vocally primed
and ready to go to communicate well wow
that makes a world of sense to just
about everyone listening to this
just try and make every call your 10 30
call so to speak
yeah but by getting physically and
vocally primed
by doing an hour and a half of something
ahead of time so you're not cold
well you know what's cool though you
don't need an hour and a half like
really
five minutes we'll do the trip ten
minutes is even better
and there's time tested warm-ups and
tongue twisters and exercises you can do
and of course we'll make that available
to anybody on this
who listens here but you can also just
google stuff but we have a whole series
of
video warm-ups that we give to clients
that can follow along
because it is a little bit different
than a sport in that when you're
speaking
it's all about this channel right here
so your mouth
your lungs your windpipe here your torso
now if you're gonna play baseball of
course it's a lot about your wrists and
things like that
communication is a little bit different
that way so there are specialized
warm-ups that you can do that are about
how
you walk and talk i love the
mind-body connection aspect yeah
you know that's like i think a bit of an
unexplored frontier with this whole
thing
which is there's this really powerful
thing that unlocks when you get people
communicating better is they feel better
and it's not just because they feel
better because they said smart stuff
when you're communicating well in order
to do that you actually have to stand up
a little bit more to have room for your
diaphragm to drop down and your lungs to
fill with air
and you actually have to open your mouth
a bit more for the sound to come out
and you actually have to use your body
in a more dynamic way so on a really
granular
level you're actually using yourself
more like an athlete and it begins to
unlock
actually feeling better you have to
breathe more that oxygen actually helps
your life so people are so focused right
now
on how sitting is bad and it is sitting
as much as we do for
you know remote existence right now it's
bad is that why you're standing is that
something you'd recommend for folks
yeah well two things so i have a stool
too that i can sit on at times because
it's not realistic to think that you can
stand for eight hours a day
you know and you want to be able to go
back and forth but yeah people should
stand
for a significant amount of time during
the day they should if they can
so if someone has let's call it a
20-minute job interview sitting or
standing
um i would say standing well that's a
very very concrete piece of
advice and i have to say that if i'm
imagining you being interviewed
and it seems like you would be more
effective standing because you seem more
comfortable
and energetic i know when i was a
candidate
if i had a choice between sitting or
standing i always stood because you were
just more energetic
so you described that you have your own
space and it's
obviously i mean in your case you're
doing this all day long how do you
create
a good first impression digitally in
terms of
having a backdrop that seems
professional without going overboard
sure well people have probably at this
point heard a bunch of the basic stuff
you want a light source from the front
so your face can be seen
you want a present background so you
have a bit of a depth of field mine is
actually
probably busier than you want for an
interview or things like that
i do it again because i'm trying to keep
folks awake
and engaged and then i can reference
things like
fox and socks if i want them to do
tongue twist or something you know what
has changed my life
uh i don't know if you have one of these
i'll see if i can show everybody
um it's one of these circle lights
uh-huh uh
that like those things yeah like i'll
show you all what it looks like i mean
you can looks like a ufo now
um but right i like this thing has
definitely changed everything for me in
terms of zooming because
you stick it there and then there's
always a light on your face
uh i think it might have cost i don't
know
30 bucks 40 bucks yeah and then you want
to have the camera roughly at eye level
which you're doing a great job of by the
way
right now now that sounds like a few
things to remember right you're like huh
three things okay what should i do
exactly
it's really simple just think of it this
way if you were setting a friend up
for a good photo when you're traveling
you would do these same things you would
not put the sun like right behind their
head
you would not make the background the
least attractive part of the scenery
and you would also not shoot them from
an unflattering angle like
up their nose or something like that so
just to the same exact three principles
when you're setting yourself up visually
for success we should talk about what to
do with interruptions among zoom let's
do that for a second
you know we've all had those zoom
interruptions so what are the best
practices
oftentimes the strongest thing you can
do when things go wrong because they
will
they're going to go wrong it's not like
an if it's a win the strongest thing you
can do is actually be transparent
in some way and so because people get
interrupted there's dogs there's pets
there's
tech challenges people can actually
embrace that
and especially if you're talking about
hiring someone
that is going to demonstrate a level of
in the moment resiliency
in the moment calm spontaneity
that is actually a good thing so when
mistakes happen people can actually just
be transparent about it
no i was trying to make a marco rubio
joke
like that or whatever it is but you know
it's funny though so just now you're
taking a drink of water that's
transparent
right you trying to hide the fact
that you're taking a drink of water not
so transparent so that's a perfect
example of what we're talking about
certainly if you do get interrupted
during an interview as long as you
seem confident and have the right spirit
then people
will i think completely accept it like
i've had my kids run in
uh all sorts of times and then sometimes
people like oh that's cute
yeah i teach i teach three f's for this
it's a little bit like
you know sticky because it's
alliterative but people remember stuff
because it's literature so it helps
people out
so we teach the idea of fake it or
feature it or fix it
and so fake it means like if the kid
runs in but no one knows if the kid's
like
right here like hi daddy there's just
doing that thing you don't have to say
like hey michael my kid's standing right
here you can just fake it great
but if the kid steals the attention of
the whole thing you can either feature
it or
fix it and feature it means just what
you did like hey my kid's here say hello
so i feel like people will be on their
way based upon
these principles alone thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode